the 11th candidate to be the leader of
the Conservative Party and by default
Prime Minister James cleverly the MP for
Braintree welcome to you about simple
question why should you be the next
prime minister well I think that we need
to deliver brexit I campaign for brexit
right from the get-go before it is
fashionable even but having done that I
think we need to reset the agenda we
need to as a party and as a government
we need to look different we need to
sound different we need to offer
something new because the British people
have made it clear that they are deeply
unhappy with the politics that we have
at the moment and I think we need to
repair our relationship with the British
people and I think I'm in a fantastic
place to do that you've been an MP since
2015 for four years do you honestly
think that gives you the qualifications
to run the government at this very
difficult time for the nation yes I do I
absolutely do because he's not just
about the time that I've had in in in
Parliament I've also I was also at City
Hall for eight years running a really
big and important part of that I ran the
fire authority and did with the
emergency planning for London including
the prelude to the 2012 Olympic
associations you got much experience of
that first well yes actually yes I have
I mean I was in business and I dealt I
did international business I was a
negotiator that's what I did that's what
paid my mortgage and actually the point
is that they're seeing all around the
world that there is a desire to have new
faces with new voices entering politics
missing now in Europe were seeing that
in America we're seeing that I mean the
problem is a lot of people are fed up
with the old but you know to be frankly
new aren't doing a great job at the
moment either rather they've look at
Donald Trump president macro you know
people want new brushes but they're not
necessarily very efficient well I can't
and I'm not going to try and justify the
record of other politicians but I know
what I know what this job needs this job
needs someone who can build a team
someone who can make difficult decisions
and then someone who can come
you negate those decisions both within
Parliament and to the country as a whole
and I've done all those three things I
know that I can do these three things
again and you're right the country is
crying out for something new and there
is a balance there is a balance if you
want lots of experience then there will
be choices put forward but if you
genuinely want to see something new and
different as I think we are seeing from
the British electorate then you have to
make a ball so for example is the
speaker right that Parliament should
have a voice on a No Deal breaks it and
potentially could stop it
but it doesn't matter whether I agree
with the speaker or not we just have to
deal with reality as we find almost the
speaker's made it clear the speaker's
made it clear that he will give as much
latitude as he can to MPs trying to
prevent us leaving without a deal and
he's and MPs have been successful that
said No Deal is still the default
position my job as the brexit Minister
is to make sure that we are in a good
place if we have to leave with a debate
I mean the reason I'm asking this is
Jeremy Hunt and now Matt Hancock have
both said leaving without a deal he's
not a runner well it is still a credible
situation we might find it is a good
idea because it's entirely feasible that
the EU you talk about president macro
he's already making it very clear he's
very uncomfortable we have the UK
getting a further extension we have to
prepare for it I know our preparations
for No Deal are well advanced and if we
had to leave without steel we could I
have never claimed and I do not claim
now that it is the most desirable
outcome above it but neither is failing
to leave but your prime you become Prime
Minister we get into October and the
choices we leave without a deal or you
do something ask for an extension or
revoke article 15 what do you do
so revoke your article 50s is totally
unacceptable it would it would rather
than then crashing out it would bring
about a collapse in the confidence of
democracy as a whole we should not
underestimate we should not
underestimate the the social impact of
politician
politicians the country is saying I
don't give on a fool at least it to
crash you you wouldn't have the cojones
to actually get out there and say look
this is all a mistake
I tell you my job is to make sure that
if we have to leave without a deal we
are able to do so and do so in good
order and I am confident that I and my
predecessor have so you don't
renegotiate but prepare for no deal we
have got to prepare for no deal I've
said that this is my vision this has
been a you see if you become anything
you wouldn't waste time going back to
Brussels and saying can we for now the
point that the point is we have had
delay and we've had delay and we've had
delay and at no point has that delay
helped delay delaying the point where we
have to make difficult decisions has
just introduced further indecision and
that's the last thing we need now we've
got to show some leadership we've got to
show some design decisiveness and I
think that actually we can by building
better relationships both within the
Conservative Party and across the House
of Commons and with our European
neighbors we can leave with a deal and
on time let's talk about you a bit you
you were in the Regular Army very
briefly well you're injured is that
right yeah I picked up I picked off a
sporting injury nothing terribly heroic
most of my time in uniform has been in
the the reserve forces and I didn't know
this you went to the same private school
as Olli Robbins I did Kirk of course
Academy no it was yeah coughs coughs in
southeast London I didn't know him he
was he was younger than me you once said
you wanted to scrap the minimum wage you
know I didn't you didn't say that no I
didn't say that
what that was was debate about
regulations and burden on on small
businesses and it was it was you know
one of these kind of like a balloon
debate at Conservative Party conference
where the idea was to kick around you
know various almost like unthinkable
ideas and that was part of the debate
was one think of ideas he said might be
a good idea it was it was it was a
discussion point in the same way that
you debate yeah this house what was your
attitude to the national minimum wage in
the living way
well what we've basic income so what
we've seen well hang on you you you're
clustering a hole they're in the same
area that's what I'm saying pic so what
so what we've seen actually is millions
of very hard-working people on low wages
lifted because the decisions that we've
made as a conservative party I'm proud
of that and it follows a long tradition
of the conservative party looking after
the people who are not as successful as
economically or financially as others
I'm very proud of that and I want to see
that continue but ultimately the best
way of living of lifting wages is to
make sure we have a vibrant economy
particularly in the small business
sector make sure they are not too
heavily taxed not too heavily regulated
and particularly this is true out of our
big cities in our towns where we have
seen real problems with economic
stagnation and that's where we really
need to see the economy bubbling up and
obviously you are playing to win
absolutely but if not you don't go there
I'm playing to win this is in fact I'm
not playing I'm in this to win because I
know I know that the the the the party
needs and the country demands something
new and something fresh something
different and that's why are there any
of the candidate I said don't go there I
don't know are there any of the
candidates who in your view are not fit
to lead the party and be Prime Minister
that we have got we are blessed we have
got a really good spectrum of potential
leaders I think that I would do better
than the others but you know I'm really
proud of the people that the
conservative parties but you could serve
under any of them really I'm not going
to talk down any of the candidates and
I'm not going to say wouldn't serve on a
row because I'm I think we've got a
really good slate of candidates rovings
land finally just on party business you
used to be a deputy chairman of the
party mm-hmm
what are you going to do about the
Michael Heseltine's and the Andrew
Cooper's and other conservatives who
voted for other parties maybe brexit
maybe in a different direction
well as it stands at the moment the
party's Constitution is what it is and I
think we should abide by that ultimately
what we should do is we should find a
way of once again being a broad appeal
political party and we should be a party
that can comfortably home
people of a range of views we have
always been a broad-based party that's
what we need to get back to yes we need
to make sure that we win over the people
that voted for us most recently but also
we need to get across to new audiences
younger voters urban voters voters from
black and be AME backgrounds we need to
do this as well as rather than instead
off and labor is starting to expel
people who didn't those laborers problem
no it's the Conservative Party going to
do that but as I say they should should
you be expelling people who voted
briggsie or voted Lib Dem so the parties
the parties Constitution is is set out
the rules are set out and all the rules
are that to remember the Conservative
Party you have to abide by the
conservative values obviously a
demonstrable way of doing that is voting
conservative I'm not voting for other
people but the point is what we should
look to do is get beyond brexit this
very very divisive issue and then in
very quick time start reaching out to
our traditional voters and new voters
cervesas no - explosions you're saying
is let's say your view my view you're
asking to lead the Tory party I think
people who vote for other party should
be so my view is that there are other
things that I want to be focusing on at
the moment and the rules are already in
place